coupe de france de football versailles
clubs amateurs de 4e division n'est
qu'un match de l'exploit celui
d'atteindre la finale de la compétition
en demi les franciliens rencontre nice
cette belle histoire ne vous rappelle
rien un petit poucet face à un
mastodonte de première division david
contre goliath mais si souvenez-vous en
2000 et je vous donne rendez vous là
devant 12 avril 2000 date historique
jamais un club de 4e division n'avait
atteint la finale de la coupe de france
en demi les amateurs de calais ont
terrassé l'ogre bordelais score final 3
buts un
dans l'équipe aucun joueur pro ils ont
tous amateurs et occupe amitié à côté du
foot pour préparer la finale de la coupe
le petit club du nord de la france se
donne les moyens direction claire
fontaine dans les yvelines le fief de
l'équipe de france de football n'ont
jamais été aussi près de jeudi reste une
marche à gravir donc on va essayer de la
préparer le plus sereinement possible il
faut pas se mettre de pression de nos
mains parce que ce qu'on va rater notre
match à calais la police s'empare de la
ville preuve de l'engouement les kits a
même sa propre chanson
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et une boutique de souvenirs ouvrent eux
mêmes exprès ses portes pour la finale
c'est du jamais vu j'arrête poste à un
poste le 7 mai 2000 après des semaines
d'attenté insoutenable c'est le jour j
en finale calais affronte nantes en car
ou en train les supporters sont des
milliers à se rendre au stade de france
pour la journée du siècle un ping pong
pour nous c'est quelque chose
d'extraordinaire c'est au tour du monde
à nous
score final 2 buts à 1 pour nantes
laventure s'arrête pour caler une finale
marquée par cette image forte
les deux capitaines soulève ensemble
trophée de la coupe de france et malgré
la défaite l'équipe fait la fête
jusqu'au bout de la nuit
c'est très grande et aujourd'hui on va
essayer de laisser de côté sa déception
et participer à cette fête qui démarre
aujourd'hui calais reste encore le seul
et unique club amateur de 4e division
avoir atteint la finale de la coupe de
france
versailles peut devenir le deuxième club
à réaliser une telle performance mais
pour cela il va falloir battre les
aiglons histoire
[Musique]